Star-Lord has quickly risen to being one of
Marvel's most popular heroes, thanks to his
role in Guardians of the Galaxy.
But just a few years ago, barely anyone — even
comic book fans — knew who he was.
His newer fans might be surprised to discover
that he's kind of a galactic jerk, even though
the Marvel Cinematic Universe made him look
more like Han Solo than Boba Fett.
Here's the dark side of Star-Lord you never
knew about.
He brainwashed the Guardians
The modern Guardians consist of some of the
universe's best warriors, but also some of
its most notorious loners.
How did Quill convince everyone to join the
team?
He had another team member, Mantis, brainwash
all of them to think it was a good idea.
Even worse, he didn't even try asking first,
he just went straight to brainwashing.
Forcing people to do something they normally
wouldn't do is like the textbook definition
of being a villain, so good job Star-Lord.
You creep.
That time he rescued Thanos
As the big bad guy of the Marvel Universe,
Thanos once killed half of all life — not
just on Earth, but literally everywhere, simply
because he could.
He also has a crush on the female embodiment
of death.
Not this one...or this one...but this one.
Everyone has a type.
During Marvel's Thanos Imperative story, Star-Lord
and Nova sacrifice themselves to help trap
Thanos in another universe, because that's
the heroic thing to do.
But while Nova makes good on the self-sacrifice,
Star-Lord finds a way out — and brings Thanos
with him.
Star-Lord's truce with Thanos brings the universe's
worst villain back into action, and that just
seems like another creepy villain thing to
do.
He caused Annihilation Conquest
In the Marvel comic universe, the first Annihilation
War basically broke the galaxy, but it never
would have happened if it wasn't for Star-Lord.
He had invited a group of Space Knights to
come update the Kree homeworld's security
systems, but the Space Knights had already
been infected by the Phalanx.
For those who don't know, the Phalanx are
basically Marvel's version of The Borg.
And at the time, they'd actually been taken
over by Ultron.
One thing leads to another, and the entire
universe is almost assimilated into the Phalanx
consciousness, all because Star-Lord thought
the Space Knights were cool.
Which they aren't.
Just look at this guy!
He's like a heroic trash can or something.
No thanks.
He endangered Earth
Earth: it's primitive and weak.
Different alien species are always trying
to invade it, and the planet always just barely
survives.
That being the case, it's not a good idea
to put the planet in extra danger, but Star-Lord
didn't read the memo.
In the comics, his father, the ruler of the
planet Spartax, basically puts a target on
the Earth, unless Peter returns to the Spartax
Empire as a member of the royal family.
That doesn't sound so bad, does it?
But of course, in true Star-Lord fashion,
he doesn't just immediately slip into a life
of royal intergalactic luxury.
Instead, he puts all of his friends and family
in danger.
To be fair, Peter's dad J'Son isn't exactly
the nicest guy.
Eventually, Star-Lord helps remove his father
from the throne, but then he just leaves,
so it surprises him when Spartax elects him
to be their next leader.
Since he's the heir to the throne and also
the empire's big hero, this should have been
obvious.
But instead of fulfilling his duties, Quill
tries to just abandon his people.
That life of luxury must be a real heavy burden.
And when he finally did take the throne later
on?
He did such a bad job that his people ousted
him.
Oh, well.
He was a lounge singer
When all of reality crashes together during
Marvel's Secret Wars, a small contingent of
heroes survive the end of the world on a lifeboat
built by Reed Richards.
When they land on the patchwork planet of
Battleworld, Star-Lord finds himself in an
alternate version of Manhattan.
Instead of getting back into the hero game,
he works as a lounge singer, until he meets
up with an alternate version of Kitty Pryde.
He finds his way back to the resistance to
help lead the charge against God Doom, the
ruler of Battleworld, but he'd probably still
be singing if he'd never run into an actual
hero.
Speaking of which...
He's insanely jealous
Peter Quill and Kitty Pryde were the "it"
couple of the Marvel Comics universe for a
bit, but their relationship took a turn for
the worse when Star-Lord decided to step up
and become the leader of Spartax, prompting
Kitty to take up his old mantle as the new
Star-Lord.
Peter didn't like having another, more effective
Star-Lord kicking around the galaxy, and the
two had a fairly messy breakup before reconciling.
Maturity has never been one of Quill's strong
suits...
“What are you doing?”
“I’m distracting you, ya big turd blossom!”
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!